Continuing in Al-Wajeez
in the book of purification, we are in
the last
chapters
in the book of purification.
This is the final point before we move
into the book of salah and begin with
the rulings on salah
and then and iqamah and so forth.
And
this is the chapter
regarding the rulings of al-hayd when he
fasts,
which is
menstruation
and postpartum.
And you may think, "Well, why does this
apply to us?"
Of course, it applies to us if
there's any
women listening. I don't think so.
But
perhaps online.
But definitely applies to every one of
us, male or female,
because we all have
mothers, daughters, sisters, and
we are to have enough knowledge to be
able to
function our respective households.
And that there not be a single member of
our household that is
functioning upon
ignorance with respect to repeating acts
of worship. This is paramount, very
[Arabic recitation]
a death a definition
of
menstruation.
And what is menstruation?
This is one of those things that does
not need to be defined necessarily.
Because it is something which is known
experienced by 99%
of all of women from humankind.
However,
in the earlier books of fiqh, for
instance, the first complete book of
fiqh ever written, which is the book
of al-Shafi'i rahimahullah, Kitab which
is later referred to as Kitab al-.
And those earlier books,
Muwatta' al-Imam Malik and so
forth, you'll not find definitions of
things that are known.
They won't define things salah.
They won't give a definition for things
wudu.
They won't give definitions for things
[Arabic recitation]
Because these are things which are
known.
We we don't need to define them. Every
Muslim knows these things.
In later books of fiqh,
predominantly after the fourth century,
when there became,
you know, a lot of
a lot of detail and a lot of
argument and a lot of debate and so
forth, we find that scholars started to
define these things in those later
books.
But really,
the best definition for
menstruation,
postpartum
is these are things which are known to
women. He says
that there is no
particular time
set for
length or shortness of a menstrual
cycle.
It could be
long, could be short, and it changes. It
doesn't have to be the same always for
every single woman.
As a matter of fact, there is a
narration in which a woman came to
Ali bin Abi Talib
in his time
and she had her cycle three times in the
same month.
Right? And this is something which is
possible. It's an anomaly, it's very
strange. Usually it's a once-a-month
occurrence, but it's possible.
Likewise, the length of it. It could be
the majority of the month
and it could be a very short amount.
It's not something which is judged by a
time limit. Contrary to a nifas,
postpartum has a time limit.
It does not go beyond 40 days in the
correct opinion as Salamah radi
[Arabic recitation]
that 40 days is the longest amount of
time there could be postpartum bleeding.
After that, it's no longer postpartum.
So,
[Arabic recitation]
this is one difference between al-hayd
postpartum
and
menstrual cycle they have the same
ruling
all through the legislation of Islam
in everything
except for three things.
And one of those three things is in
their length
they don't have a minimum but they have
a maximum.
Postpartum has a maximum
and menstruation does not.
He says
He says and a nifas
postpartum this is the blood which comes
out of
a woman after she has given birth
because of giving birth. This is called
postpartum.
And the longest it can be is 40 days.
The longest it can be is 40 days.
[Silence]
He then mentions a narration in a sunan
on the authority of Salamah the
prophet
Alaihi Wasallam's wife
she said that a woman
who was experiencing postpartum she
would
spend 40 days at most at the time of the
prophet Sallallahu alayhi wasallam
experiencing that postpartum.
[Silence]
So, with respect to postpartum, we have
one of two things happening
for it to end.
Number one,
she reaches 40 days.
Number two,
it stops.
Whichever of those two things happens
first, this is the end of postpartum.
So, she will either
reach the end of her postpartum,
right?
Or
40 days at absolute most.
After that, even if blood is still
coming out, it is not considered to be
postpartum. Maybe clinically it is.
Maybe it could be referred to, you know,
in people's common tongue as postpartum,
but in the legislation of Islam,
postpartum is 40 days. At 41 days, it's
no longer referred to legislatively
[Arabic recitation]